Alright guys, so I have an example for the daily bias, as you can see on the daily timeframe
and I'm looking at USD CAD, it happened recently actually, like a couple of days ago.
So you can see we have this external liquidity marked out here, and where do you see the
draw on liquidity, which is our internal liquidity, this fairly gap right here.
So that is our draw on liquidity right here.
We took out this low, which is an external liquidity, so let's drop down to the one hour
timeframe.
Remember on for the daily bias, we go from daily to one hour.
So let's drop down to the one hour timeframe.
Now we're simply looking for a market structure shift that supports our high timeframe narrative
and right there, what you can see is we have a shift in the market structure.
Now this right here is an auto block consecutive bearish candles right as I explained in the
auto block 2.0 video.
So right here, what you can see, this would have been our entry point.
We go long here, right for every simple and we look to target this level here.
And now that is your bread and butter model going for 5.55 RR.
You see we get our entry here and it is currently a weekend that I'm recording, so I'm pretty
much sure that's going to take out this level.
But as you can see how beautifully it distributed to the app site, we also had a fairly gap
here.
So if price filled the fairly gap, also they were going to auto block and you could say
a breaker block.
So you can see you can easily identify your targets, which is the beauty of this concept.
Although if you were using the 5 minute timeframe, you could have taken multiple entries here
and I want to talk about those later in the video when we get to the more advanced concepts.
So let me give you guys an example for the monthly bias once again and then I will do
one more for the weekly and one more for the daily and then we will move on to the next
chapter.
I want you guys to understand these concepts very clearly and I'm like, yeah, I'm very
confident you guys are going to absolutely kill the markets once this course is out and
you master this.
Of course you will have your back test first, give it a month or two, back test these concepts
or I don't know if you are a quick learner, you could just give it a one week of back
testing and then get into the markets right away.
So let me give you guys an example for the monthly bias once again.